hervé des is her rédacteur en chef de
port et corridors conçoit avait dit
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france donc l'opération import mort
aujourd'hui lancé par les dockers cgt
contre la réforme des retraites on a
peut-être moins entendues alors vous
peut-être non parce que vous êtes dans
cette presse spécialisée mais on a peut
être moins entendu s'exprimer les
dockers sur la question de cette réforme
des retraites qu'est ce que ça
changerait pour ce texte du gouvernement
écoutez d'abord que juste pour remettre
un peu en perte et il est les éléments
en france il ya 19 morts et donc c'est à
dire on est un élément il y en a 19 dont
sept grands ports maritimes les les
dockers ont connu une réforme en 2008
sur l'organisation du travail pour
s'aligner sur les ports du nord
aujourd'hui ils sont face à un projet de
réforme des retraites
allard indépendamment de toute opinion
sur ce projet qui luttent ce contre
lequel et l'udc ou depuis le 5 décembre
ya beaucoup d'éléments qui ont fait que
les porcs sont bloqués aujourd'hui il ya
des effets sur toute la toute
l'industrie delà de la chaîne logistique
le projet en soi il est pas il concerne
pas que les deux terrains qui concerne
tous les travailleurs français donc le
sujet il est pas dockers ou portière il
est national
avant toute chose et c'est ce que
rappelle la fédération nationale des
ports et docks de la cgt alors justement
concrètement si on a compris on venait
bien de nous l'expliquer que ça va
concerner tout le monde
qu'est ce que ça changera pour les
dockers en en particulier quels sont
leurs litiges spécifique alors et le je
pense que et il faut remonter sur à la
réforme de 2008 quand ils ont une
quand on il arrive en 2008 ils ont
négocié à l'intérieur de la branche la
pénibilité
qui est elle
une pénibilité uniquement pour cette
branche de l'eau caire qui prévoit un
départ trois ans avant la date
là on va dire que si jamais vous deviez
partir à 62 ans la pénibilité telle
qu'elle est prévue dans la branche vous
permet de partir à 50 9 en or avec ce
projet de réforme
ce que dit la cgt la fnpd-cgt le l'âge
de l'âge de départ d'art culé et donc
l'âge de départ de pénibilité a reculé
de la même chose deleuze du même ordre
de gaulle ou de partir
à 59 ans comme vous pouviez y prétendre
si vous aviez une activité pénible
vous ne pourriez partir qu'à 61 ans ce
qui pour un dock est requis et
portiqueurs c'est-à-dire question rue à
40 mètres du sol ou qui est dans des
conditions parfois de très beaux chaleur
dans les bois quand il fait très chaud
l'été ou de grand froid quand en plein
hiver en plein air peut être un peu
difficile à vivre
justement est ce que ces deux cas il
pense pouvoir tout de même obtenir
quelques concessions du gouvernement
soit dans vos jeux et goûter moi j'ai
rencontré les responsables à de la
fnpd-cgt j'ai rencontré des responsables
des organisations patronales
ils restent tous on peut camper sur
leurs positions pour le moment on n'a
pas tellement de vision d'avenir
les laits trafic sncf très perturbée
font que les ports français souffrent
énormément ou aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
ya une sortie une solution une sortie
pour les fmb des lacunes c'est le
retrait du projet pour les industriels a
qu'une c'est l'arrêt des mouvements et
puis peut-être des négociations mais je
pense que chacun essaye un peu de camper
sur ses positions et honnêtement vu ma
chaise d'observateurs les choses ne vont
pas en s'améliorant
alors je sais m'en vais de walscheid
vous avez l'impression que
les situations va se radicaliser cette
opération port nord va durer jusqu'à
quand et surtout peut-être pour
intéresser les autres téléspectateurs
avec quelles conséquences
on est mesure peut-être pas alors c'est
vrai que les médias se font assez peu le
les cours de ces ports de ses mouvements
dans les ports on l'a vu là avec votre
journal
très intéressant mais alors le les npd
de voix ce rayon devait se réunir
aujourd'hui de ce qui nous avait dit ils
doivent décider vendredi si le mouvement
est reconduit pour 72 heures de port
nord la semaine prochaine ou si il je
cite élèves la contestation à la
quantité élevée la contestation
ils ont été jusqu'à dire s'il le faut on
fera des mouvements de 96 heures par
semaine voire des mouvements illimités
donc ça signifie quoi ça signifie que
toute seule qui nous est apportée en
france et c'est quand même à un volume
assez important ne passera plus par les
bois foncé à passer par des ports
étrangers
on peut passer par des ports étrangers
maintenant on risque d'avoir en effet
des des problèmes de demandes de
certains produits
parce que ils mettront plus longtemps à
arriver dans le commerce que que
d'habitude donc c'est toute une
réorganisation
aujourd'hui beaucoup de commentateurs
vont dire anvers barcelone bilbao gènes
se frotte les mains de sa et permettent
cosmonautes gagne des trafics
grâce à la grève portuaire mais bon les
ports étrangers ont toujours été
meilleur que les ports français jusqu'à
présente aujourd'hui c'est difficile de
savoir qu'on n'a pas encore tellement
les effets le premier réflexe était de
brut
si demain le brut ne n'arrive pas à
rentrer dans les raffineries
on va très vite être en rupture de stock
sur sur l'essence
si le main on n'a pas on a un certain
nombre de troll
de première nécessité qui doit venir de
l'étranger qui n'arrive pas on risque
d'avoir mes produits des ruptures de
stocks de certains produits
c'est toute la chaîne logistique
internationale qui est gay mais ammann
voir qui va changer
qui va être modifié et qui risque d'être
modifiées sur un très long terme ce qui
pour les ports français et qu'elle va
c'est dramatique
l'interview merci je suis sam élément
c'est que ces professionnels les années
sur patronale s'inquiète aussi beaucoup
d'avoir de savoir que edouard philippe
qui est un havre est d'origine n'a pas
su prendre la mesure de ce secret ça
j'ai eu beaucoup de gens viennent de
toutes les peurs pour dire ça merci
beaucoup en tout cas hervé un délice de
nous avoir fait voir plus clair un petit
peu sur ce conflit également fait en
tout cas cette vision du conflit des
retraites vu depuis les dockers merci à
vous